il est pas mal julien clerc vachement
bien beau vachement beau hein
ouais mais il est pas libres et pas
libres non merde ah bon c'est de me lève
à faire marquis tirailleurs de temps
longtemps peut-être temporaire en jeune
co animé incroyable contient un email
pour l'instant je lui fini son portable
on sait jamais
ce que vous entendez services d'état
la ligue est un bon soir sa main ben oui
quel accueil je suis content car la
normale attendu normes star maintenant
alors avec ce disque en plus
alors là c'est encore mieux je suis sûr
alors vous êtes dj non c'est ça qui a
écrit sur votre passeport et a écrit
quoi dj c'est vrai c'est un métier
reconnu
ah ben oui quand même depuis le temps
ils allaient pas marqué vendeurs
d'ecstasy non plus il était obligé de me
tâter de la crainte c'est vrai que
chaque fois que je passe la douane -
fouilles quand même cet article cela
donne avec une valise de 10 c'est
automatique
l'accord dit aussi c'est bizarre quand
même accueilli fouillot toujours en
corner by va arriver à t'en fais pas la
danse y ait moins david après succès de
just little more love
l'été dernier vous sortez cette année
just one day
david guetta versus but we just one day
qui est une reprise de heroes bien
entendu tout le monde a reconnu la
chanson comment ça s'est passé avec
bowie heures
mais en fait c'était c'était pas du tout
sens censées sortir officiellement
ouais donc il ya dans le langage des djs
qu'on appelle les bootleg va dire qu'on
se fait des mix que pour nous parce qu
on a envie de passer des trucs que les
autres ont pas donc j'ai fait une
version 2 0 c'était un morceau que
j'adore pour pouvoir la passer en soirée
et je joue dans un festival en hollande
voilà il ya cinq six mille personnes et
émeutes
incroyable la réaction génial donc à la
suite de ça il ya plein de dj qui
viennent le voir en vrai mais c'est quoi
ce truc on voudrait bien avoir une copie
tout ça donc j'ai pas le droit
d'utiliser un simple de bowie bon mais
c'est pas grave dit j'en fais pas
beaucoup j'ai en fait 500 un peu par
passion les venge en dix pirates puis
voilà et je les envoie un peu au dj
influents et il se trouve que j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance puisque ça a plu à un
des dj qui travaillent sur radio one qui
est la plus grosse radio en angleterre
ils se mettent à passer ça un jour j'ai
un coup de fil au studio du manager
lawyer de david bowie donc je dis je en
dérision là je me suis fait choper super
élite albrand plein j'ai un peu peur et
puis
on m'écoute et on a écouté avec david
bowie on aime beaucoup fait une
composition a donc après être blanc je
me mets à être un taureau rouge et à
faire des bonds dans le studio est en
fait ils ont été super et non seulement
ils ont accepté qu'on sorte le disque
mais il aurait pu me dire bon ben voilà
ça va être david bowie d'un tout petit
remix de david guetta comme l'a fait
pour kylie minogue par exemple est en
fait l'annoncé
c'est un grand honneur pour moi donc
d'avoir mon nom à côté de celui là j'ai
bien vite contre david c'est énorme
ben ouais je suis assez fier c'est
vachement bien